let your voice be heard we invite you to
capture the public imagination and use
creativity artistic expression and
innovation to explain why regulations
are important to everyone and motivate
others to participate in the rulemaking
process
almost every aspect of our lives is
touched by federal regulations even
before you leave the house in the
morning government regulations help set
the price of the coffee you drink the
voltage of electricity in your alarm
clock and the types of programming
allowed on the morning news you see
federal agencies develop an issue
hundreds of rules and regulations every
year hundreds of rules and regulations
every year while Congress writes a
statute to create a new program or
change in existing one they provide an
outline of the program federal agencies
implement the statutes programs and/or
changes and they do this by developing
and issuing rules and regulations most
people are familiar with how a bill
becomes a law but most people don't
understand how federal agencies develop
condition roles most people don't
understand how federal agencies develop
and issue roles or that everyone has a
chance to provide their input into those
groups let your voice be heard let your
voice be heard let your voice be heard